Jennifer uh just a wild Affair in
today's game and uh after the opening it
felt you were pretty much busted and it
showed on your face as well at some
point you weren't even watching the game
it felt like you're fighting you're
fighting but you don't believe in your
position as much yet you managed to get
back into the game how did you do
that um well I think I just got a pretty
bad position out the opening I don't
really I don't I am prep this and I
don't play this so I I just I don't know
why I did this but I guess I just didn't
want to play anything else so I I was
like let's just play the nimzo don't
really know it but um so not the best
position but I was just you know trying
to make it interesting for a little bit
and then I think when she let me um get
my Knights like in the center and they
were able to stay there and you know
there wasn't any breaks and I think I
was doing starting to come back into the
game at that point point but for a while
there it did look pretty bad absolutely
and it was after the time control how
did you assess position uh the position
after the time control at this point
excuse me I don't have the right game
somewhere around here after this trade
you have the C Pawn you have the
beautiful Knight in the center but at
the same time white has her trumps as
well especially this Pawn on A4 that
could potentially round down the board
very quickly how did you assess
it um honestly I thought I had really
good chances here because it's just very
easy for me to play if I'm able to get
my um Pawn push then also you have to
worry about checks along the diagonal
from A7 B1 actually if you go back I
don't know if I was supposed to play um
f F5 here yeah no5 was the best this
we're talking about F5 was the best okay
because I wasn't sure if we should do
queen E5 first cuz Queen E5 doesn't let
um Bishop C3 like what that happened but
this was
yes so this is like oh I mean apparently
Queen to uh F3 and after that Rook to D1
to get the Rook behind and supposedly
I'm faster than you are with the c
Pawn Yeah Yeah so this is what um I
thought about for a long time but I
decided to go with f five first
absolutely and of course that opened up
the game it wasn't easy in fact even at
this point the computer is still saying
that this is equal but with some crazy
moves in the position yet I do want to
see that final second of yours one more
time maybe you haven't seen it yet I
know you felt it but tell us your
feelings going in through this through
the motions at this
[Laughter]
point no I
yeah I mean my question is how did you
stop time like you had one second and
you managed to make a move and hit the
clock that's right because you see see
there is one second and you haven't even
picked up your queen
yet right there that's when you pick up
your queen you have one
second
boom that's the longest one second in
chest man that's
crazy no when I when I realized that I
was like there's no way I'm about to
flag this game right now cuz I've done
this so many times in the past like it's
embarrassing how many times I flagged a
game of increment just because I like
forget sometimes I'm about to runn out
of time and then this happens but I
somehow caught it um in the very end but
yeah that that was really embarrassing
for a second wow guys questions for
Jennifer after that game after that
finish I'm
still yeah yeah yeah um wow um just so
many questions and uh confusions and
everything else it wasn't your
tournament Jennifer but I have the feel
feeling that you really like Fighting
Chess you're like today you fought your
way back it's your openings your
openings are really letting you down
you've had bad positions coming out of
the openings you had a bad position
today you fought your way back in is it
just schoolwork is pre pre preventing
you from really improving your openings
what's what's the problem Jen um yeah
that was the main problem going to this
tournament I just hadn't reviewed
openings in forever and then right I
probably should have tried to squeeze in
time but it's it was just difficult and
then here I didn't have the best prep um
honestly sometimes no prep um like
yesterday against Alice that was
genuinely like going to that game I just
did not feel like I just didn't want to
play that day cuz um I had to take like
a test so I just stayed up all night so
I like all nighter like zero sleep so
didn't really prep all that much so that
was just horrible feeling just like
horrible day and then um yeah like going
to this round I mean I just like I feel
like I also just kind of been not as
motivated to like do prep here even
though I just because I wasn't you know
feeling the tournament but I really
should have cuz like that I think that
was one of my problems cuz before in the
past like even if I didn't like do so
well I'd always like still try my best
towards the end but I think I was just
struggling a bit um especially when I
was like balancing a lot of different
things so um yeah I think I just like
need to really think about how I wanna
manage my time in the future and you
know U set different priorities because
you know realistically like looking back
at this tournament um this was like a
bit too challenging for me to play this
at during this time in my school year
for this semester especially so um you
know I did you know I did come play some
interesting games but I I did wish I did
did things
differently uh Jennifer I don't have a
question but I have a compliment first
of all congrat congratulations on
winning this absolutely crazy game but I
have to say that you really keep us
entertained the last Armageddon game
with Bishop G4 you know being pieced
down and then just like fighting it
through and winning that game and now
just winning this game uh just fantastic
really
congratulations thank you thank you um
actually like before before this year
like back before like I won my first US
Champs I would play spoiler a lot cuz I
would always be playing someone who was
like in contention the last round and I
I just I always love doing that like I
mean not love it but like it's just kind
of fun because everyone's like watching
your game and I mean the pressure is on
them so it's like an interesting thing
absolutely Jennifer thank you so very
much we'll see you at the closing
ceremonies and here are our Champions
the